[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre cette
fille choisir en attendant les cloches
et les oeufs en chocolat je vous propose
une édition spéciale pâques le sommaire
de ce jeudi 18 avril pour ne négliger
aucun détail pour des fêtes de pâques
réussi deux créatrices vous nous
apprendre à réaliser un objet de
décoration trophée lapin de pâques les
fermes de gally organisent leur
traditionnelle fête des oeufs des
ateliers bien sûr une chasse à ces
petits trésors en chocolat
julien berland sera avec nous pour en
parler les équipes de l'est s'affrontent
ce week-end en quidditch aux
clayes-sous-bois sport inspiré de
l'univers harry potter pour lequel il
existe même une fédération française
avis aux plus créatifs et habiles de
leurs mains
elena et camille vous propose de
fabriquer un trophée lapin de pâques
outre coûté quatre heures de réalisation
indications en images camille et elena
se sont rencontrés il ya quelques mois
sur le réseau social
instagram toutes les deux passionnés de
créations artisanales
elles ont pris l'habitude de travailler
ensemble pour attendre la chasse aux
oeufs un trophée lapin de pâques
première étape avec elena le lapin en
poupe je vais faire l'arrière de la tête
de notre petit lapin donc c'est très
simple l'arrière de la tête les unit je
me contente de bien fixer la matrice de
façon à ce que des deux moitiés soit
bien que les mêmes contre l'autre je
bloque mon fils et je commence à tourner
pour couvrir
avec de la laine de couleur différente
ouveillan sucré et les éléments du
visage en prenant garde à bien respecter
la symétrie ont rajouté quelques tours
assez lâches pour faire les oreilles sur
la partie supérieure du pompon vient
ensuite le découpage l'on découvre enfin
la phase de son contenu donc maintenant
on va sculpter le la pointe pour les
oreilles et les nightly des aiguilles
est feutrée qui vont venir mélanger les
fibres de la laine et lui donner une
autre texture les yeux même chose vous
pouvez vous servir de l'aiguillât
faudrait pour enfoncer les poils des
yeux et donné sept critères plus naturel
quand vous m'en plaindre de son côté
camille ses talents couture et crochet
s'occupe de la partie textile elle
commence par fabriquer un noeud en
découpant 3 rectangle de tissu de
tailles différentes
un pliage précis pour former des tubes
c'est ensuite les assembler pour
constituer notre nom en tissu et là on
va juste fermé par quelques points à la
main le petit tube à l'arrière d'une
partie la plus technique le cadran en
crochet pour cela qu'elle me va venir
couvrir un cerceau métallique avec trois
méthodes de crochets différentes les
mailles serrées doivent être par
multiple de 6 elles serviront de base
pour les deux autres tours cette étape
minutieuse et la plume
reste ensuite le fond l'étape la plus
simple et la plus rapide
on va venir prendre une feutrine épaisse
quelque chose qui a un petit peu de un
petit peu de tenue sur lequel on va
venir coller un cercle de tissus qu'on
aura des coupés
ne reste plus qu'à coups à fond et
cadres en avant de procéder à
l'assemblage final votre trophée lapin
de pâques est fin prêt pour venir
décorer la chambre de votre enfant
si vous n'êtes pas aussi doué que nos
deux créatrices vous pouvez toujours les
contacts et sur leur compte instagram
est passé commande pour le week-end de
pâques les fermes de gally se mobilisent
depuis une quinzaine d'années une fête d
eux et sont organisées julien berland
vous êtes responsable du site de
sartrouville bonjour bonjour alors je
vois que vous n'êtes pas venu les mains
vides qu'est ce qu'on nous avait apporté
ce que les enfants vont pouvoir
fabriquer c'est ça voilà c'est ça je
vous ai apporté un petit échantillonnage
des activités qu'on va proposer ce week
end
donc il ya bien sûr la traditionnelle
chasse aux oeufs donc les enfants vont
aller chercher dans nos prêts les oeufs
en plastique qu'ils iront échangé contre
les en chocolat qui sont là et puis
autour de 100 leur propose aussi tout un
tas de découverte donc à saint cyr
l'école il y aura des activités autour
du des métiers de la laine avec une
fileuse qui sera là le tondeur également
et puis les enfants pourront réaliser
des petits des petits tableaux comme ça
créatif avec 2 c de la laine en fait on
à la laine brute du mouton qui ensuite
lavé
à l'extérieur de la ferme et qu'on nous
rend sous forme de laine feutrée de
l'aisne pardon card est donc cette laine
cardée on peut l'utiliser soit pour
faire des petits tableaux qui est là ou
alors les petites perles de l'aisne
qu'on fera aussi à la ferme de
sartrouville
voilà qui a plusieurs activités comme ça
tout le monde peut venir tout à fait
donc c'est ouvert aux enfants de 3 à 12
ans pour la chasse aux oeufs et puis
bien sûr aux adultes qui les
accompagnent et donc tout au long de la
journée de 10h à 17h par contre il est
recommandé de venir assez tôt parce qu'à
partir de 15 heures
la fête bat son plein il ya beaucoup de
monde justement il ya moyen de
s'inscrire
alors on peut s'inscrire sur le site qui
s'appelle fun booker donc on retrouve en
lien sur le site les fermes de gally
points comme et donc les inscriptions
ont lieu jusqu'à samedi minuit donc on a
même le temps pour les retardataires
puisqu'on annonce du beau temps ce week
end on peut décider en dernière minute
ailleurs il y aura également des places
en vente sur place et on est quand même
aux fermes de gally donc bien sûr les
animaux ont leur part d'actions bien sûr
les animaux seront là donc les brebis
fraîchement tondues à sartrouville et
celle de saint cyr qui se feront
entendre en direct avec thomas letondeur
qui se fera un plaisir d'expliquer aux
grands et aux petits
pourquoi et comment on tond les moutons
donc sauvé qu'elle ne veut pas que sa
marque aussi le début des vacances
scolaires vous avez des animations comme
ça pendant toutes les vacances voilà
pendant toutes les vacances donc à
partir de ce week-end et pendant une
quinzaine de jours nous serons ouverts
tous les jours de 10h à 12h30 et de 14h
à 18h sur les deux ferme et on proposera
des animations enfants l'atelier du pain
qui a lieu trois fois par jour et puis
d'autres ateliers à 15h30 qui changent
régulièrement
donc on peut avoir des petits exemples
de ces ateliers alors par exemple à
cette saison va proposer un
un atelier découverte des empreintes
donc on fait confectionner aux enfants
des empreintes
voilà des empreintes en argile donc on a
des matrices et on imprime dents larges
et et les enfants repartent avec le
petit exemplaire comme ça non bah on a
fait on a fait le tour ça donne envie de
visiter cette ferme de gally merci
julien berling d'être venu sur notre
plateau merci à vous comme d'habitude on
pouvait retrouver toute la programmation
sur le site internet des fermes de gally
des chasses aux oeufs vous pourrez
retrouver dans différents espaces
loisirs des yvelines
la bergerie nationale voit les choses en
grand avec des cloches qui passeront
durant toutes les vacances scolaires ces
cloches qui n'oublieront pas non plus
les animaux du zoo safari de thoiry avec
des jeux adaptés à leurs besoins
alimentaires
une chasse aux oeufs avec énigmes le
château de breteuil ajoute plaisir de se
creuser les méninges à celui de
recueillir du chocolat et bien sûr les
comptes s'adapte avec une séance inédite
sur le thème de pâques de la faune
chocolat à l'oeuf de poules vite preuve
offre des gallinacés à ses habitants
vous avez jusqu'au 19 avril pour vous
inscrire et peut-être adopté la poule
attitude
l'objectif est bien sûr de prendre soin
des nouvelles habitantes de votre jardin
tout en réduisant vos déchets une soirée
dédiée un maître de l'épouvanté votre
rubrique dans les selles saint
quentinois de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
nationale cette semaine nous vous
proposons une soirée spéciale john
carpenter la c1 mais obstiné à
strasbourg y donc forcément j'en fais
beaucoup mais c'est surtout parce que il
ya beaucoup de ces films qui ressorte
ces derniers temps et puis parce que
c'est un cinéaste important des années
80 aux états unis mais qui a influencé
le cinéma mondial
alors on avait passé the thing on a
passé les aventures de jack burton dans
les griffes du mandarin et puis là on va
vous faire une soirée
trois films de john carpenter puisqu'il
y en a quatre qui ressorte qui sont
ressorties cette année le premier film
ce sera un vase et los angeles
alors c'est un film qui étrangement
intéressant aujourd'hui puisque en fait
c'est un film qui parle de le monde dans
lequel on vit maîtrisé par des
extraterrestres qui seraient cachées etc
mais quand on met des lunettes de soleil
spéciales on arrive à les voir et à voir
que toutes les publicités sont des
messages incitatifs à obéir sans dormir
regarder la télé etc etc
le deuxième film qu'on va vous proposer
c'est un de mes petits chouchous c'est
un des plus connus c'est le film qui a
fait que john carpenter est un peu
arrivé au sommet c'est donc encore et
toujours avec snake plissken new york
1997 grand grand film dans un futur
improbable new york manhattan est
devenue une prison et donc on
on retrouve notre héros qui doit sauver
le président tombé dans cette prison et
puis le dernier the fog a le seul vrai
film d'horreur de la soirée qui interdit
aux moins de 12 et qui donc sera
présenté en fin de soirée
je me ferai un plaisir de vous
accueillir de vous présenter tous ses
films et de vous dire tout ce que je
sais sur ce cinéaste et je vous promets
qu'on passera une très très bonne soirée
tous ensemble donc à vendredi 19 avril
dès 19h30 au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
[Musique]
comme le disent les apprentis sorciers
de poudlard de bouffe les balais des et
de la seule équipe de quidditch des
clayes-sous-bois ne voleront pas mais
assurons tout de même le spectacle la
discipline inspirée de l'univers harry
potter est aujourd'hui organisée en
fédération française ce week end a lieu
la seconde journée du championnat pour
la ligue de l'est
l'efsc les siens affronteront les
équipes de paris lyon et de lorraine
vous pourrez venir les encourager au
stade jean françois bayle tr min
l'entrée est libre dès 10h et des
initiations seront proposées dans sa
tournée d'ile-de-france la médaillée
olympique et double championne du monde
techwin de gwladys epangue s'arrête à
trappes ce samedi 20 avril vous pourrez
partager un combat avec elle au gymnase
broustal de 14 heures à 16 heures pour
éliminer entre deux oeufs en chocolat le
vélo club de montigny le bretonneux or
gagner sa course cycliste de pâques un
circuit de 3 km à réaliser en 19 ou 26
tours selon son niveau 150 coureurs
seront attendus dès 8 heures sur la
ligne de départ de l'avenue du parc et
maintenant direction paris pour un
mariage entre cultures footballistiques
et culture arabe
[Musique]
l'histoire du monde arabe
l'institut du monde arabe consacre une
exposition sur le football une
chronologie de onze histoires pour
raconter les liens entre ces deux
cultures reportages des pôles bi look et
de nos confrères grand paris maillot
trophée ballon rond débarque à
l'institut du monde arabe
entrez dans l'univers du football pour
une exposition dont le but est de
déterminer la place des sociétés zara
dans ce sport en plus des reliques de
grands joueurs et grande équipe
la scénographie mise en place pour
l'événement immerge de visiteurs dans
une ambiance de stade
chants de supporters vidéos de matchs et
photo de légende accompagne le parcours
qui racontent aux histoires marquantes
du football on s'intéresse à beaucoup
thématiques ont appris ces onze
histoires ça peut parler d'un joueur
d'un match d'une compétition
on a suivi un fil chronologique mais ce
n'était pas le but initial on voulait
vraiment exploré toutes les thématiques
possible c'est-à-dire men barre avec un
joueur franco-marocain à l'histoire
incroyable vous voulez parler des ultras
et leur rôle très important dans les
révolutions arabes où le psg s'est
totalement métamorphosée à la suite à
l'arrivée avec l'arrivée des qataris par
exemple donc on voulait explorer tout ça
et ses onze histoires pour les onze
jours d'une équipe ne paraissait évident
au delà du côté sportif
foutez monde arabe explore également les
enjeux sociaux politiques et religieux
autour du foot avec par exemple la
création de l'équipe du fln pendant la
guerre d'algérie ou encore celle de
palestine plus qu'un sport le foot c'est
une culture
l'institut du monde arabe selon moi doit
s'ouvrir à toutes les formes de culture
d'expression collective le foot
en fait pleinement partie à travers le
foot on peut raconter l'histoire des
différents pays y compris le nôtre en
france et se relayer à des joueurs
venant de pays du maghreb nous le
rendrons m'a d'ailleurs ici un terme en
asie dan et à d'autres bref à travers le
foot vous pouvez raconter la vie de
chacun des pays
c'est un merveilleux miroir de
l'évolution des sociétés foot et monde
arabe
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer
disponible jusqu'au 21 juillet prochain
et c'est la fin de votre 7,8 loisirs
merci de nous avoir suivis bonnes fêtes
de pâques
et bonne semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
oh
[Musique]